lori lachlan is headed to prison the
actress was sentenced today now the big
question becomes
will hollywood welcome her back after
lockup michelle turner has the story
lori was sentenced to two months in
prison her husband massimo gianouli
five months just as the prosecutors had
recommended
the actress fought back tears in court
apologized for her role in the college
admission scandal and said
she believes in redemption i watched
both federal sentencing hearings on zoom
lori told the judge she was ready to
face the consequences and throughout the
hearing her emotions seemed all over the
place
perplexed worn down disbelieving and
remorseful
the judge wondered why someone so
accomplished would do something like
this for what
he asked for the inexplicable desire to
have
even more lori asked to serve her time
at the federal prison in victorville
about 90 miles outside of l.a lori's
husband massimo was actually sentenced
first at his zoom hearing the judge
called the cheating scandal a
breathtaking fraud
and said the fashion designer took
advantage of privilege quote
you are not stealing bread to feed your
family you have no excuse for your crime
that makes you all the more blameworthy
massimo who was stone-faced and
emotionless
apologized to the court and said he
takes quote full responsibility
both lori and massimo must surrender
themselves by november 19th by
pm pleading his case massimo's lawyer
said this family has become the face of
the scandal
adding olivia jade and isabella have
been bullied
and massimo said he regrets bringing his
wife
into the scheme in light of today's
sentence can laurie make a comeback
well martha stewart sure did after
serving five months in prison
that's three more than what was handed
down to lori today
if you believe in yourself everything
will be fine
martha served time in a minimum security
facility and had a prison job just like
lori will martha was a pro at waxing the
prison floors
if you have a job you do it well that
place was sparkling when i
left the domestic diva even sparked a
trend when she walked out of prison in
this poncho crocheted by a fellow inmate
it was cold that night and i had a pair
of jeans on and a
t-shirt and i thought well maybe i'll
just put on that poncho and i wore it
and the rest
is kind of history
e.t was there in 2005 when martha
launched a new talk show just after her
release
she was wearing her ankle monitoring
device today
martha's worth an estimated 640 million
dollars
my customers believed in me and she's
thriving in quarantine
last month we talked to her about that
sultry pool selfie that went viral
that's definitely a thirst trap